items that came out yesterday chris out
of the clear blue sky
lsu receiver jamar chase opting out
of the 2020 season the consensus number
one receiver top five pick balitnikov
award winner
last year and the report is it's not
because of covet 19 it's because he
wants to spend the year getting ready
for the nfl draft and look i
if that's true and and here's the thing
i hadn't seen odd the
cop but covent gives you cover to say
i'm just not playing this right right
right that the guys
like the first one i remember arguing
zealously should sit out the whole year
is davey and clowny
after he did the rock'em sock'em robots
thing and popped the guy's helmet
off and everybody knew the guy that was
going to be a star and i think it was he
had one year after that
whatever it was right it was one year
clear that hey was in the barn
you don't need to play when he played it
felt like he was tentative and maybe
worried about an injury that would screw
everything up and then leonard fournette
the same deal
sit out the whole year not just the bowl
game not just the meaningless games on
the back end of the schedule
just skip the whole season and say i'll
see you next year at the draft when i'm
finally eligible to play that
if that starts happening on a widespread
basis that's going to change the rule
from three years after your high school
class graduates down to two well
that's why jamar chase supposedly is
doing it chris and
and i support it it's a business
decision to not subject yourself to a
serious injury when you know
you already are on the brink of being
one of the highest
drafted players when you're finally
eligible to enter yeah i mean
covet 19 you know uncertainty of the
year
offensive coordinator left quarterbacks
gone
you know i think all those things
probably play into it i do find the
timing of it i guess a little odd
but like just like to echo echo this
you know this yeah this if he comes out
in the draft last year he's the first
receiver off the board
there's no doubt about it he's a top 10
pick he's the best receiver in college
football
these are the type of players where i
wish college football in the nfl could
come to an agreement
on or something or maybe just change the
rule altogether but just go
wait we've seen this guy for two years
he's like in a special class
he's in a special class why does he have
to waste his time
right we can draft him to go to war but
well you can't leave college to go
become a pro
like that makes no sense that's just
stupid
the guy's nfl ready right now you put
him in the league he's gonna be a
superstar
right now if he threw him on a team so i
do i have no problem with these type of
scenarios right now
with the current state of college
protect them from themselves
we have to protect them from themselves
chris don't you understand
they're not big enough and strong enough
and mature enough to go play in the nfl
we're protecting them from themselves
like the coaches of their nfl teams
won't otherwise protect them
if a coach decides to draft a guy that
they decide may not be ready to protect
himself
it's all ludicrous it's this slippery
circular argument
that college football makes to keep
guys longer and the nfl and the nfl pa
are complicit
in it they're keeping guys from going to
the nfl
when the nfl is otherwise ready for them
all in the name of
preserving the free farm system it's one
of the reasons why college football is
inherently corrupt
top to bottom it's one of the reasons
why i don't even really enjoy it that
much anymore yeah i i hear you it's it's
it's a lot of bs there right now there's
no doubt i i get and you know mike
i used to be one of those guys that used
to say like
you know they got to protect them from
themselves a little bit but that that
that is that's such an
old world thought i've changed my mind
on that three years ago because you
to what you said a little bit like
it'll become very apparent if he goes to
an nfl team and he can't protect himself
or he's physically overwhelmed and then
he's just not gonna make the team and no
you made a bad decision
or maybe they see potential in them and
realize whoa the guy's gonna get a
little bit better
you know let's not kill him right now
let's you know just slowly bring him
along for next year
but yeah if a guy got to a team and like
physically wasn't able to hand up
the coach is going to be like put them
in there keep getting them killed
we'll make them tougher that way no
that's not going to happen so that is a
total bs argument
the coach is a human being the players
are human beings they would realize if a
player was totally outmatched that way
and honestly i'd have a hard time
thinking that any player that was
outmatched that way would want to make
the jump anyways it's really going to
only be
the elite of the elite of college
football they're going to go
screw it like dexter or trevor lawrence
of clemson
it's a rare few guys every year where
you go hey he's ready
grown man sophomore don't give a damn he
can play right now
let me say this though there will be
guys who are sufficiently delusional
that i think they are among that group
that's why you have to give them a path
back if they don't get drafted that's
one of the things jim harbaugh
rightfully has been pushing for the head
coach of michigan if the guy goes
and he's not drafted he can come back
let him come back now
you can't go back if you take money and
look
one of the things i'm hearing about
chase and he's got every right to do
this i say take it while you can
opting for a marketing guarantee chris
are you familiar with the marketing
guarantee it's not really money
it's a it's an advance on the money
you'll
make signing autographs doing
commercials
right all the things off field right
that that
and and my understanding is there may
have been a seven figure marketing
guarantee that committee
convinced jamar chase to say see you
later lsu which
getting back to the point we made
earlier about the advice i'd give to a
son a nephew a cousin a friend etc i'd
say
take the money and run right out of
there jamar chase get paid while you can
because the school isn't going to pay
you and this school's putting you at
extra risk
in 2020 with the pandemic chris
yeah no i i mean you're right we'll see
where it goes but uh
jamar chase i understand it i think the
timing's still
weird there's probably more to discuss
there but regardless uh good for him to
move on
another hour pft live still to come
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports